hey everyone we've lost on the call in
the office it's a Nintendo switch sure
uptown let's do what their kids call an
unboxing like that but before we get
into that if you want to see some games
a little more switch content check out a
livestream that Peter Brown did I think
Bob Hanley was also on it
yeah and they played a various games
there and one piece they nearly kissed
when they did us forget a mini game if
you want to see that hot kissing action
head to GameSpot calm or youtube-dot-com
forward-slash GameSpot hit the subscribe
button if you enjoy this video and like
it as well alright interesting enough
okay so this is a box it's made out of
some sort of cardboard
oh and there is then there you go um see
you next week guys
I'm bugs all right first things first
yeah a little red joy con nice you have
oh I'll have the red one
I'll have the other blue one is
significantly I'm gonna it looks less
red than I remember it
yeah well we were under steer lights so
meantime we both use these at the
Nintendo switch event mmm
one thing that I will know our highlight
is that for a grown man's hand they're
pretty small yeah I found it very
difficult for some of the games but then
you know that how you get that
satisfying thing where you hold like a
small bottle of alcohol or something
like a miniature you feel like a giant
every time you say a Nintendo game
you're gonna feel like you don't this is
way like that this is it this is the
mean the bad boy that's gonna fall all
the way
but luckily Nintendo have thought this
through I thought and they've got any
nice little spend pop it up ah yes this
is you this whole thing that makes makes
the toy cars look like a dog have you
seen this yeah
so you've got actually for those money
on for those of you at home
it's got rails on the slide so you just
slide it on in and that's now it's a dog
no dog no ears their eyes eyes are a bit
ice Q he's got a little problem he's got
a little eye problem is need or or we
got the important information this is
what people are really here for the
important information that important
information document you'll see this on
eBay in a couple days time
will you look at that probably oh
they're they've they've reborn the whole
strap thing strap so but you need to be
careful about enjoy cons these are these
serve a double function Dave did you
know that no tell me more about the
double function oh well if I can figure
out how to get this joke on our I may be
joking
Dave help me know so these are actually
they there says rails on the little one
guys little button don't make the same
mistake I did a little bun so these are
the rails and you slide these bad boys
on and there you go you've got you'll
never know about your TV you will
shoulder buttons for your little switch
enjoy Conn there's the bonus this which
is nice I put this on the right way
though I hope so I don't know if these
are these are gonna come off in forever
yep - or forever so that should pretend
that don't happen
here we go append out we need a new
switch so very own like a stand just get
these out of the way
this is what I look like when it's in
front of your TV except dusty oh yeah
black consoles man yeah upset me that's
like the one good reason to have like a
white console you know free AC it looks
really nice they seen one of these
before
Wow is that as a hey Lucy HDMI cable uh
thankfully though like I will give them
props for this the whole power brick
situation is way simpler I'm I'm don't
wanna alarm you but like we've had this
out of the box for about Oh 20 seconds
is covered in dust is my so smudged okay
so it slides in like effortlessly I
don't know I think I felt like it's a
bit yeah I I need like some feedback
yeah I'd like a little more like the
clicks into place
it clicks into place by like you just a
little bit and then you've got put it in
if it was kind of like when you put in a
snooze cartridge heredia snow like it's
nostalgia oh boy don't blow this
yes I'm still fully having a hard time
getting this strap off the joy car so
this is the main power rebooter up it
and like you can tell LEDs this is if
you ever need it like some indication
and this is meant to be a portable as
well tiny cable look at this
it's just like a 3ds child you almost
see I I expected it to be a bit heavier
just just because I think I I when I
think about battery life I think heavier
something is my battery it's got no more
they said there's like two and a half
hours playing Zelda you have something
like two two and a half hours to three
hours or so there's a lot of like on you
told what the stands got like a back
panel that which comes off cable
management I'm a fan of that yeah
a there's proper cable management so you
put it in here and there's a little unit
here don't know if you can see it's got
the USB HDMI and AC adapter ports there
what do that handy I'll fix the
fingerprint it's also got a USB on this
side but I think these are USB 2.0 ports
whereas the one inside is USB 3.0 we
should get that hot transfer speeds cuff
you need them you could have take your
amiibo amiibo you're me you're me all
right we're gonna Reeboks this now do we
need to bother with all this yeah this
is this is the robot I've dropped all
that and it's gone
it's just gone no yeah I need the
plastic ID you really want the plastic
though I know there's people out there
like me who will want to Reeboks this
look at that reboxed just put it in
there we go it's good as new ish
nintendo stealing all well the only
important information that you guys need
to know is make sure to LIKE the video
if you enjoyed it subscribe to GameSpot
and we'll see you next time
[Music]